my comic book skills are like I'm here
oh my four-year-old son drives better
complex than I do my dream superhero is
very sensitive kind guy whose gift is
posing in bodybuilding contests and also
helping people understand one another
the world over but we call him mr.
understanding does he have a weakness
his weakness is he's just too kind
sometimes he just feels too much happier
when I mean he just has great is he bald
does he have hair Yee's has to be bald
because yes you understand the feelings
of the people who have no hairiest be
identified with them mine is gonna you
know gonna be dude it was not
superheroes but I like to be in love
with my super Johnson I liked it he is
holding a baby cuz he's a dad and he's
like carrying a diaper bag oh and also
wait a second wait and then back here is
he also cleans the house so here's the
bucket husband man does he have a secret
weapon his secret weapon he can I didn't
balance a child well yeah chores also
doing chores this sounds great I love
this
do you have an idea of what their
superpower is in yes what is it
all the cool ones in one good yeah I see
it's looking a little familiar yep drawn
some inspiration huh
Superman who would have thought why is
that the dream superhero Superman is the
best of us in the sense that he has gone
through all the trials and tribulations
of slings and arrows of growth of being
hated of not being wanted of wanting to
do the everything that humanity not
being able to achieve it being
disappointed in himself and still coming
back fighting every time it's so ugly I
don't know even I can do better
Alif what's yeah let's see it you're
sure yeah I'm sure it's great oh she's
adorable yeah this is horrible yeah
what's her name she's kind she's
good-hearted she's happy she's positive
she's an inspired glossy girl maybe posi
girl like positive girl
okay posi girl he was born in the
Silicon Valley it was meant to help us
okay make us better but he's in a lot of
ways stolen our lives what's their
personality like he adopts our
personality I feel like you've thought
about this before I'm into it oh there
we go
I should have known I bonehead
I thought man would be played by Zac
Efron he's got Zach's got the legs for
it